today Tutankhamun's treasures are famous
worldwide but Tutankhamun himself has
always been a shadowy figure a mere boy
propelled to the throne at nine and dead
by the age of 19
dwarf by the great Pharaoh's who
preceded him and those who followed in
his wake his life story was largely
unknown since ancient records were
destroyed in antiquity
for more than 3,000 years Tutankhamun
lay almost forgotten here in the
traditional burial ground of the
Pharaohs Egypt's Valley of the Kings
until in November 1922 archaeologist
Howard Carter and his wealthy patron the
Earl of Carnarvon made the greatest find
of the 20th century they'd stumbled upon
a treasure hoard beyond their wildest
dreams in all 5,400 artifacts many of
them wrought in solid gold the Egyptians
of Tutankhamun's era prized the precious
metal because they believed it would
survive for all eternity they called it
the flesh of the gods
the find was a worldwide sensation every
other royal tomb had been stripped by
grave robbers long ago but here
everything was still in place
Lord Carnarvon had unearthed not only
priceless treasures everything
Tutankhamun believed he would need in
the next life was crammed into his tomb
connivance extraordinary finds set
Egyptologists on a race to fill those
gay parole Zin our knowledge of the
mysterious boy King Highclere Castle in
southern England is the home of the
present-day 8th Earl of Carnarvon his
great-grandfather the fifth Earl spent
10 years and much of the family fortunes
searching for the tomb of King Tut
a momento in the family vaults reveals
how the triumph was swiftly followed by
a mysterious death there are many ideas
if you disturb an intact tomb for fairer
than something terrible world before you
this in fact is my great-grandfather's
cutthroat razor which led to his
death he got bitten by mosquito then was
I'm shaving in the Winter Palace Hotel
and he didn't pay attention to the
rather nasty mosquito bite nicked his
face there and let the bacteria in the
old developed blood poison before the
treasures could even be fully examined
the man who found Tutankhamun was dead a
victim some said of the curse of the
Pharaohs
at the precise moment of his death in a
Cairo hotel room the Egyptian capital
was plunged into darkness was it a
simple power cut or something more
sinister back here at Highclere exactly
the same time his beloved little dog
Suzy suddenly died as well after a long
how she expired so there were some
spooky things that happened at the time
of the death of my great-grandfather
[Music]